dire au secours la droite de revient est
de faire pire que tout ce qu'on a jamais
vu dans ce pays en matière de brutalité
sociale de loi injuste et de
persécutions contre les travailleurs
jamais personne
au cours des 15 dernières années n'a
parlé à la cgt et à force ouvrière comme
vous êtes en train de le faire mais qui
vous aide pour vous permettre ça qui
vous a élu quel est votre famille
politique que d'autre que vous le fasse
on pourrait le comprendre
après tout ce serait dans l'ordre de la
polémique démocratique mais vous vous
n'avez pas le droit de parler comme ça
valls et hollande
si vous êtes pour qui vous prenez vous